welcome back everybody as we all age our
health needs change exercise and diet
become even more important but changes
in our lives can affect our interests
and ability to be as healthy as we can
be so jc talks to an expert from
southwest medical associates the
sponsors of this next segment for more
information
hey erica thank you so much for joining
us today and today it's all about diet
and exercise and it's extra important
with diet and exercise when it comes to
older adults what are some of the key
areas that they should be focusing on
absolutely so inactive older adults tend
to lose ground in four areas that are
extremely important for staying healthy
and that is strength endurance balance
to avoid falls flexibility
good news is you can maintain and
restore these areas with physical
activity additionally you know exercise
can really help aid against depression
and weight gain now what are some
options for for keeping active when it
comes to your mentally and physically
what are some of the options that older
adults have
well you know first and foremost there
are a ton of no-cost low-cost options i
know there are a lot of older adults
that are on a budget but in that case
there is swimming you know a lot of the
communities out here have swimming pools
that is a great low impact exercise for
older adults golf it's another great way
to get back in touch with nature and
also get some physical activity in and
low impact exercise classes what is the
best type of physical activity got to
pick one or is there one that they
should steer towards
well i always like to say that some
physical activity is always better than
none right but
i always aim at trying to encompass as
many types of activity into your routine
as possible so you should really work on
five types of activities that's aerobic
or also called endurance exercises
anything that will help strengthen your
muscles improve your balance increase
your flexibility and fifth i always like
to say again always try to do more than
one type of physical activity such you
know as those aerobics and muscle
strengthening definitely want to do more
than one let's expand on that what are
some more non-sports related activities
that people could do
um dancing you know i know a lot of
folks that love dancing uh whether it's
at a community center or at a friend's
house or in your own living room dancing
is always a great way to get some
activity in window shopping which is one
of my personal favorites you don't have
to have to go out there right you don't
have to go out there to spend but uh you
can definitely get those steps in at the
mall garden on your patio
call a friend or a family member
sometimes it's the social interaction
that you need just as much as the
physical interaction
play a game of cards do a puzzle read a
book all of those things are really
really going to help you stay connected
and and increase your your mental health
and stability so tell us what is
southwest medical doing to promote
physical activity
yeah southwest medical has partnered
with the op and care community center
which has locations conveniently located
on the east side and the west side of
the las vegas valley these locations
offer physical activities yoga line
dancing in addition to social activities
such as bingo and cooking demonstrations
thank you to southwest medical
associates for sponsoring this segment
locations across southern nevada like
she said
702-877-5199 is the number you call for
more information or you can visit
smalv.com we'll be right back